let's say that we run a car dealership
and we have 11 salespeople and we record
the number of cars each of the 11
salespeople sold in the past week so
this is you know that's one of them 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 so we record how much
each of them sold so maybe one person
sold maybe they sold five cars maybe the
next person sold seven cars maybe the
next person sold 10 cars and so that's
how we would do it so we're going to
record all of that but then weird we're
told that the median car sold is six so
if we ordered all of these numbers so
let's just assume that we ordered them
all from least to greatest so maybe and
I'm just making up numbers here maybe
this is for this is for maybe this is 5
5 5 6 7 7 8 9 10 the median car sold me
that the middle number here is going to
be 6 now we don't know whether all of
these other numbers are the actual
numbers I just made those up but we know
that the middle number needs to be 6 so
let me just fill out only the middle
number so the middle number if you have
11 data points the middle number is
going to have 5 on either side so that's
that one right over there 1 2 3 4 5 1 2
3 4 5 so we know that the median we know
the median actually let me do that
purple color that median is going to be
6 now the other thing we know is that
the range of cars sold is 4 and let's
remind ourselves the range is the
maximum number of cars sold minus the
minimum number of cars sold and if we
have sorted all of these out this if we
take if this is our max right over here
because we've sorted them all out and
this is our min right over here our
range is going to be our max minus - our
min so let me write that down so you
take your men and your max you have your
range range is equal to the maximum
minus the minimum and they're telling us
that that is 4 this range is 4 so the
maximum minus the minimum the difference
between the
the number of cars that the the most
productive salesperson sold and the
number of cars at the least productive
salesperson sold that difference is
going to be four
so given all of those assumptions giving
all of that information I'm now going to
give you a statement
and our challenge is if we assume
everything I just said is true is this
statement going to be true or is this
statement going to be false or do we not
know so let me write this down so is
this going to be true false false or do
we not know do we not have enough
information to say it's for sure going
to be true for sure going to be false or
for sure we don't know and so I
encourage you to pause the video now and
try it out
alright let's so let's work through it
together this is kind of a fun puzzle
here where we've been given some clues
and then we have a statement we forget
can we can we make this statement can we
say it's true or can we say for sure
that it's false or do we just not know
so a couple of ways a couple of ways to
to tackle it one way to tackle it is
well look one of the salespeople must
have sold six cars if the median sold is
six and there's eleven salespeople here
the middle number here that that if we
order it one of them must have sold six
cars if we had an even number here then
that would be the average of the two
middles but if we have an odd number
here that is literally the middle number
of cars that somebody the number of the
middle number of cars sold so someone
sold six cars so if we assume if we
assume it we're trying to find a world
where someone sold more than ten cars so
if someone sold six cars is there a way
with a range of four that someone sold
more than ten well just think about it
let's just assume that the mint is six
we don't know if that the mint is six
but let's just try it out if the minimum
is six
if the minimum is six what's the maximum
going to be well remember the range the
range is equal to we know that the range
is four the range is equal to the
maximum minus the minimum maximum mine
the minimum and so the maximum in this
case would be 10 would be 10 max would
be equal to would be equal to 10 if the
min is equal to 6 and instead of colons
I'm going to write it equal sign if the
min is equal to 6 then the max at most
can be equal to 10 and we can't take a
higher min because we know that the 6 6
is going to be one of the values we
could try a lower minimum value could
say the minimum value is 5 or 4 or 3 or
2 or one
but then the maximum would go down even
more because remember the maximum is no
more than 4 larger than the minimum so
if we assume 6 and we know that one of
the salespeople sold 6 cars then the
maximum that any of the sales people can
sold is 10 and so the statement at least
one of the salespeople sold more than 10
cars that's got to be false that's got
to be false now there's another way that
you could think about it you could
assume that someone sold more than 10
you could assume in the last example or
the last way of thinking about it we
assumed that the min was 6 but now let's
just assume let's just assume that
someone sold that let's just let's just
try it out let's see if it's possible
it's just assume that the max is 11 that
someone sold more than 10 cars if the
max is equal to 11
what's the min going to need to be well
we just have to remind ourselves range
is equal to max minus min so 4 is equal
to the maximum 11 minus the minimum so
11 minus what is equal to 4 well 11
minus 7 is equal to 4 so if we assume
that the maximum is 11 then the minimum
is going to have to be the minimum is
going to have to be equal to 7 now can
the minimum be 7 and is when your median
is 6 no if your median is 6 that means
you have if you that means if you have
an odd number of data points that means
one of the data points is 6 and if you
had an even number of data points that
means that the middle two are going to
average out to be 6 which means you even
have data points that are less than 6 so
your minimum can't be 7 you're going to
have a value that is at least as low
least as low as six so your assumption
can't be true can't be true so once
again the assumption based on the
statement can't be true
this statement is going to be false